in this video we'll quickly review the
enzymes which are involved in DNA
replication this is a High video for
csiet I Jam get or gatb if you are
preparing for any of these exam this
would be super useful for you so stay
tuned till the end so this is the
replication fork and let's quickly
review the enzymes which are associated
with it so we are looking at the
procaryotic scenario this is the DNA
polymeris 3 which is a principal DNA
polymerase involved in the replication
procedure it synthesize new BAS pairs it
has distinct components like clamp
loader sliding clamp tow protein and we
would review this in bit more details
later on then there are primes which
form the RNA primer required for the DNA
synthesis then there is DNA helicase
which unwind the DNA double stranded DNA
and there is DNA gyas which is basically
a type of Topo isomerase which uh
introduces negative super coils in the
DNA and thereby unworn it un wound the
DNA in a meaningful way such the entire
process of replication can happen and
the DNA doesn't entangle too much so now
let's quickly zoom into the overall uh
enzymes and try to analyze their
function so first let's talk about the
DNA gyes DNA gyes is Topo isomerous type
2 its function is to relieve the
torsional strain introduced during the
uh replication process it breaks the DNA
molecule and relieve that torsional
strain so it prevents the DNA super
coiling during the unwinding
process then there is DNA helicase
obviously it unwinds the double stranded
DNA molecule by breaking the hydrogen
bond within the base pairs of the
DNA and it's important is to create
single standard DNA template for
replication then there is primes whose
function is to synthesize short RNA
primer with which is complementary to
the DNA strand and thereby start the
process of DNA synthesis it kind of
gives the polymerase a uh PR primer to
start the entire synthesis so the DNA
polymerase cannot start the process by
itself this small RNA primer is the key
step for synthesizing the DNA then the
DNA polymerase obviously the main job of
the DNA polymeris is to synthesize New
Strand basically it can extend the
existing RNA primer at the three prime
hydroxy group it can incorporate
nucleotide in the three prime hydroxy
group obviously this lead to the
incorporation of new base and this is
The copier so this copies the entire
template Strand and add up new
nucleotide against that particular
template
strand now DNA polymerous 3 enzyme is
the key uh enzyme involved in
procaryotic
replication so it has different
components almost nine subunits here is
a clamp loader or gamma complex here is
siding sliding clamp sliding clamp is
loaded by this particular clamp loader
complex and this is STW protein extra
crystallographic structure reveals this
kind of NR structural details and each
of these structural details reflects on
its functionality as well which we have
already
reviewed now there is another thing
which is called single strand binding
protein which binds to the single
stranded DNA and prevents its
reannealing otherwise it would have rean
and formed the base pairs again so these
keep the DNA as a single standard
template such that the replication
process can happen then the last enzyme
is the anas it joins at the
discontinuous okazaki fragment on the
lagging strand so basically it forms the
last phospher Bond so if we zoom into
those broken region you can see the five
Prime phosph phosphate group is free and
the three prime hydroxy group is there
between these two a phospher bond would
be formed and that is triggered by the
lias and it's a ATP dependent uh
reaction so obviously for replication
and many steps associated with
replication ATP is required now at the
end which is very important we should
revise quickly the type of polymerase
present in bacteria and the
ukar so when it comes to procaryotic DNA
polymerase the principal DNA polymerase
is the DNA po 3 it is involved in the
chromosome replication then DNA Paul 1
is generally used for primer removal and
DNA repair DNA Paul 2 and Paul 4 both
are involved in DNA repair Paul five is
involved in transl DNA synthesis which
is an SOS repair
process let's talk about the eukariotic
scenario in the ukar the DNA PA Delta
and Epsilon at the major one the Delta
is associated with lagging strand
synthesis whereas the Epsilon is
associated with leading strand synthesis
then there are other VAR as well like
DNA PA Alpha Beta gamma Theta mu Kaa
then there are many more but the DNA PA
Alpha is important and Gamma is
important gamma is a three subunit comp
complex which is required for
mitochondrial DNA replication DNA Alpha
is important for primer synthesis so
this has the prim as activity and DNA
Paul beta is important for the base
exision repair this particular info
sheet is really important for any kind
of competitive exam so I hope this was
useful let me remind you that the
replication initiation in the procaryote
is very different than the UK carot in
UK carot there are involvement of
cycling cdk complexes especially the SAS
cycling and there are associated
component with it so it's bit different
in case of ukar if you want to learn
more about the eukariotic versus
procaryotic initiation part you can
click on the video on the eye button to
get the detailed explanation of it see
you in the next
video
for